now the NHS is unsurprisingly proving to
be a big issue in the election campaign
our joining us now from Lester is
Labour's shadow Secretary John for
Nashua thank you for being on the show
this morning and before we move on to
other issues around the election
campaign I just want to get your
reaction to the interview with Prince
Andrew I'm not sure if you heard it but
what did you make of it I'm not I've not
seen it yet i've seen the social media
reports of it but I'm not you seen the
interview hopefully I'll get the chance
to watch it later today but I think I
mean I mean I just think from what I've
seen on social media it's the way in
which epstein the attitudes towards
Epsilon I mean the I mean no one should
be above the law in these things and
look you know what was going on with the
trafficking of young women is absolutely
despicable and I hope the authorities in
the US I mean obviously understand has
killed himself I thought that I hope the
authorities in the US can get to the get
to anyone else who was involved in this
it's I mean there's trafficking of young
women and abuse of them absolutely
appalling and I've not seen the
interview so I'm not gonna comment on
I'm Prince Andrew but you know I mean
what we've seen about with the Epstein
case I mean just just shocking I
understand you don't want to comment on
Prince Andrew but do you feel that he
should have apologised for his
friendship with somebody who was a
convicted sex offender well I mean he
gave his explanation as for his
friendship into why he was staying at
his apartment I'll leave it for others
to judge and whether his explanation is
was apologetic or not but I think the
key thing is now that they the young
women who were abused in the United
States can get some justice obviously
they care and get the ultimate justice
because Epstein has killed himself but I
hope they can the authorities in the
u.s. can ensure that some justice is
delivered for those women who were
abused in this absolutely disgusting
case okay and can move on now to the
election campaign and some of the
policies that you are promising labor
wants to see free dental checkups for
everyone in here so what exactly is the
plan that you're proposing so what we're
proposing today is that we will scrap
the charges for
a dental checkup and which is a check
get your mouth checked getting your
teeth checked getting a scale and polish
if necessary getting x-ray if necessary
it's called the band 1 NHS checkup which
which you have to pay around 22 pounds
for the moment we're going to scrap that
would be free checkups and and we
actually think this is really important
because we do have an oral health crisis
in the country you've got more more
people using these I don't if you can
see it this is this is a sort of dental
kit you can buy from online or from a
sort of pound shop more more people are
doing what it's called DIY dentistry
because they cannot afford to go and see
a dentist their teeth get worse and
worse and worse and they try and do
fillings on their own teeth we have
stories of charities that usually
operate in the developing world or the
poorest parts of the world operating
with mobile clinics in places like
Jewsbury we have stories of people
trying to pull out teeth with pliers or
trying to superglue in dentures and of
course we have a real crisis amongst
amongst children over a hundred thousand
children admitted to hospital in the
last few years because of tooth decay
and actually when you look into that
look into it a lot of parents don't
realize that children get free dental
check-ups so we think by expanding
access will also have knock-on effects
from improving children's oral health as
well I'm definitely enjoying the
interview property brought along today
just looking at the cost of this policy
450 million pounds a year according to
labour now people who are on low-income
benefits already time to pay and one
charges so isn't this quite a lot of
money for a service that is already
offered to people who can't afford it
well we want a universal NHS which is
why we think this is the correct thing
to do but of course yes there are some
people on benefits who do get free
checkups but but also there are people
on benefits you don't and sometimes get
huge fines because of it but there's
also a lot of people in low paid work
zero hours contracts temporary work work
of that nature you cannot afford a
check-up and as a result because they're
not going to the dentist fifty percent
of people haven't been to the dentist in
the last year for a checkup
their teeth are really deteriorating
which is why we have this absolutely
outrageous phenomena of so called DIY
dentistry on the
increase and ultimately what it means is
more and more people going to hospital
over a hundred thousand people every
year presenting at A&E because of
problems with their teeth or going to
see a GP because of problems with their
teeth so it's actually costing the NHS
money as well so we think this will
relieve burden some of the burdens on a
and ease which we know are under intense
pressure you saw the you saw the figures
this week the worst ane waiting times in
history they are on record under this
Tory government so we think this ill
relieve some of that pressure it'll
relieve some pressure on the GP we all
know how hard it is to get a GP
appointment you know that's why we're
going to invest in training more GPS and
and interested and providing more GP
appointments so it will leave some
pressure on the wider NHS as well I'm
interested as well because John
McDonnell has said that he wants to an
end private sector involvement in the
NHS as contracts run out he wants to
bring them in-house but the majority of
dentists are actually private
contractors so how does this work
because what we're talking about is
reversing the privatization we've seen
in recent years we're not talking about
ripping up the fundamentals of the NHS
because in 1948 when the NHS was created
the GPS were essentially private
contractors as you say dentists the
private contractors what we're talking
about is the more reach just the right
yeah yeah but no but we're talk what
we're talking about the more recent Tory
privatization we've seen typically for
example because of the Health and Social
Care Act which this government brought
in a a children's health contract in an
area will be handed over to Virgin Care
an actually the urgent care don't win
the tender they sue the NHS it's those
sorts of contracts were bringing to an
end this sort of constant competitive
tendering of contracts which is actually
wasteful its bureaucratic it creates a
fragmented system when we should be
joining up different different health
bodies in a local area so we're going to
bring that to an end
that's a patient's accommodations okay
but but the GPS and the dentists and
some of the you know opticians have had
private contracts with the NHS since it
was created what we're talking about is
these contracts which in recent times
children's health contracts off
example a patient transport contract
which in Sussex went to affirm that this
didn't even have any ambulances
this is non-emergency ambulatory
contract it went to a firm you know
ambulances they subcontracted to umpteen
over firms two of the subcontracted
firms went bust and patients were left
on their doorsteps waiting when they
should have been picked up for dialysis
appointments it that shows you that Tory
privatization is wasteful and it's not
in the interests of patient care we're
going to bring that racket to an end
we've just been speaking to Brandon
Lewis about the concept of potty plans
for immigration he said quite clearly
there if people vote conservative
conservative government would try and
bring immigration down what about a
Labour government would you like to see
immigration go up or down
I'll tell you something every general
election I fought the Tories have made
these promises every single general
election sorry Immigration Minister get
I know but the Tory Immigration Minister
gets wheeled out to say this if they
ever delivered of the Eck I mean you
believe him I don't want to be five to
lose he says that now that we're out of
the EU there'll be more ability to
control you know well I am actually
really there is not that they all right
yeah what is what Labour's policy is
here and what would a Labour government
like to see would you like to the
immigration go up or down we want a
balanced approach to immigration and
what that means for the NHS is if a
hospital trust thinks that a surgeon or
a nurse or a midwife is qualified enough
to come to our country to care for a
sick and our elderly and offers them
that opportunity then they should be
allowed to come to our country to care
for our second our elderly what actually
the stories are doing is imposing a
nurse's tax on nurses across the EU who
want to come here even though we've
always always relied on European nurses
in our NHS they want to impose a tax on
them to come here and care for our sick
I do not think that is a sustainable or
credible approach to the stuffing crisis
in the NHS when we know we're short of a
hundred thousand staff was short of
40,000 staff it was revealed yesterday
that NHS staff are working a million
extra hours a week unpaid because the
Tory understaffing
in the NHS it's a really really simple
question would a Labour government like
to see immigration go up or down
no a Labour government will have a
balanced fair approach to immigration
that means down well a because look what
Brandon Lewis is saying it's gonna get
it you know if we've got these targets
he's gonna go down they've never
delivered on that the reason the
government but they never deliver and
the reason they know they haven't
delivered on it is because that is not a
sensible way to run an immigration
system your honor in an immigration
system based on the needs of your
economy and the needs of sectors in your
economy so as we know in the NHS we've
always relied on international
recruitment the NHS should be allowed to
continue to recruit internationally and
ethically of course but we should be
allowed to recruit internationally and
as I say if a hospital needs a surgeon
or a hospital needs a midwife or a nurse
they shouldn't be restricted by the
government's hindrances from recruiting
they are restricted at the moment and
it's partly though I it's not the only
reason why but it's partly why we have
such a workforce crisis in the NHS at
the risk of sounding a bit like a broken
record would a Labour government like to
see immigration go up or down and I'm
still confused I don't know because well
we're not well labour government is not
going to stay at an arbitrary target
about the government are because they're
not credible they're never delivered
they've never been delivered for ten
years under this Tory government and
every general election campaign
these Tory ministers get wheeled out to
make this claim to promise it and do
they ever deliver it no because they
know it's not a credible sensible
approach to managing immigration okay
and I'm keen to talk about another
really important issue which is am
Scotland and whether or not a Labour
government would grant a Scottish
independence referendum jeremy corbyn's
been talking about this this week
originally he said that the Labour
government wouldn't grant Warren in the
first term in office he then said it
wouldn't be granted in the first two
years so can you just clarify what the
policy is on this really important issue
look look a referendum on in defense of
Scotland it's not our policy we don't
believe one will be should be granted
look it's up to the Scottish people to
demand what they want but what you don't
believe it's in the interests of the
United Kingdom we believe the interest
of the United Kingdom
our that we stay together because we are
if you like stronger together as one
United Kingdom
so when Jeremy Corbyn says it's not a
priority for the first term it that is
the position of the Labour Party so it's
the first term not the first couple of
years yes we're not offering a
referendum we're not offering a
referendum on Scottish independence
again this is a a Tory line because that
because they because they want to say
those there's a sort of a Scottish
referendum coming which will break up
the United Kingdom it's not true
what if the SNP win a majority in
Holyrood they will say that that is then
a mandate to request another referendum
and if a Labour government doesn't grant
one then you're blocking the will of the
Scottish people well you know something
when you look at the state of the
Scottish NHS which is also failing on a
lot of its key target so naturally in
its banners actually cut quite savagely
some of its more in England we call the
public health budgets like addiction
budgets for drug and alcohol services
I'll actually be campaigning for the
Richard Leonard of the Scottish Labour
Party and I'm confident that we can get
a Scottish government elected in the
next set of Scottish parliamentary
elections when they come along I'm not
gonna deal with the hypotheticals of
what happens if the SNP win because I'm
confident we're going to get a Labour
victory up in Scotland okay
and now just finally list you might say
that this is another hypothetical
question in fact I'm sure you probably
will and but doesn't win the next
election if you don't win the election
that's a big-ass hypothetical I knew
you're gonna say that live fight is
gonna what the Labour Party is gonna win
and we're gonna rebuild the NHS so we've
not got elderly people languishing on
trolleys for hours and hours and hours
we've not got cancer patients waiting
beyond two months for treatment and so
that I um people get the mental health
support they've been so clearly denied
under this Tory government okay Jonathan
Ashworth thank you very much for being
with us today thank you